this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised it is a perfect summer's
afternoon for a battler to be soaring
about in the heat waves that are coming
up from the earth it's a very different
sort of afternoon than it was sort of
morning it was very very big change in
the way that's a lot hotter and bright
blue skies there not a single cloud as
well my name is Kristen on camera I've
got sins oh and it is a very warm
welcome to all of you on this beautiful
Sunday afternoon from South Africa I
hope that you all having a wonderful day
night wherever you may be and I hope
that you will engage with us for the
duration of the afternoon remember you
can do that by using hashtag spoiler on
Twitter or at if see on YouTube chat and
hopefully it'll be a good afternoon
we're going to go and try and see if we
can follow up on where Hassan is and see
what he's up to and whether or not he's
still there from this morning how did I
say Who I am sins oh did I say did we
forgot I don't know
so one of those afternoons there
hornbills are making so much noise up
for look there you go well done good
Tristan it's all hardwired in there yeah
I think I've got something wrong with me
because I can't even remember three
seconds ago I'm like a goldfish this
afternoon hopefully it's not going to
carry on that way but anyway so this
morning we stayed with us on a quite a
while after after the show finished and
between myself frame Jamie and the
trainees we pretty much spent most of
the day with them and he managed to
steal his kill back this this morning so
he stowed it back then lost it and
instead it back again and managed to
hoist it up a tree before the hyenas
really kind of got too much of it so you
didn't lose a little bit of it but not
much on all things considering those
hyenas was so full from whatever else
they a class night that they just
couldn't really actually fit too much
more in and so he got lucky
that husana and that means we got lucky
because now he should theoretically not
be too difficult to find this afternoon
well that's the theory anyway you know
with Hassan and it's not always the case
he might sometimes giving
a bit of a runaround and kind of make
you work a little bit but I think we'll
be fine I'm sure he's still there
like I said trainees are the last ones
with him and that was a while ago not
that long ago about an hour ago they
lived him and he was still sleeping away
underneath his tree very happy with
himself
I would imagine right now it's not too
far from where we are so it'll take us a
little bit of time just to get there but
while we do that
let's send you to one of my colleagues
who is joining us this afternoon the
ever entertaining and full of drama
James Henry so he can say good day to
all of you
good morning know I've made a mistake
there let's pretend let's start that
again shall we
I've live good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this end of the sunset Safari
on this Sunday afternoon we are driving
now down towards Chitra Dam very large
waterhole where hopefully there will be
some elephants having a drink it has
been very hot today I think they said it
was roughly 36 degrees Celsius out here
which i think is about 95 yeah
35 and 95 zone just over 29
what is that only 29 degrees it can't be
it's much hotter than that it's absolute
rubbish anyway ah 32 and 89 there we go
ago we got it straight now that was my
fault I didn't remember it so we're on
our way to children damn please do talk
to us of course using the hashtags for I
live on Twitter you can send us your
questions you considers your comments
you can send us your insults if you'd
like to can't promise we'll address them
all but you can still send them or you
can use the chat stream on YouTube we've
got Craig Batman on camera today that
was his bat --is-- thumb flying past the
lens like a whisper bat very little
free-tailed bat perhaps I'm not sure
what kind of bet he is and that's pretty
much the housekeeping complete so now we
can get on with our game drive
interesting stuff going on to the hyenas
and with the lipids today hopefully
those interactions will continue wait
stop Chris we have our first animal oh
look craig impala
now if you look carefully you'll see
that these Impala are not in a good way
they really are not feeling very well
and that it's because of the dry season
but what you can see is that there's a
little bit of green flush on those
bushes and so a tough times hopefully
pop over and what is eating is the black
monkey thorn Senegal iya Berkey I
beautiful now David Gotham burger too is
in the middle of a big storm but I
believe that he's opened the flaps so
that he can show you something will
floating across the grassland a very
good afternoon and welcome to the mara
triangle Kenya and from very small
impalas we came in two huge animals the
elephants my name is David as usual with
me on camera is Archie Archie good
afternoon and we have a very big storm
that seems to be coming if you look way
out there
in the background a but from having
Ellie's days like a very huge storm you
can see the wall of rain out there it
feels a bit chilly for me as much as the
temperatures 80 degrees Fahrenheit and
27 degrees Celsius but I think because
of that rain there it feels very cold
for me remember we love oh it's
wonderful to get questions from you and
should you have any nice comments of the
rain and elephant together send them
through using hashtag Safari live on
Twitter as usual ahead of Ellie's here
and I wouldn't know what the thinking as
they are anticipating the rains to come
I can hear the thunderstorms and I guess
they can hear them as well so what do
you want to do I just want to port for a
little bit there's one elephant I've
seen either is missing one task but also
the trunk seem to be short doesn't have
a full trunk and I would just a little
bit close and find out what could have
happened to it not that out no but the
things that will happen genetically we
got elephants that are born or do not
develop or grow the tusks we got some
the turbine with one task
and also we got others that are born
without a single task now all right your
Linux there's one just first the other
way we're gonna show you in a minute
she just fisted the other side way out
there
okay if you go to the one fella
this one looks fine don't close to us
both trusts are in task intact pulling
the grass from the ground they'll have
they'll sometimes check the grass to get
rid of soil and should there be anything
else that they may not want in that
munching or in that food they'll also
shake it and remove it sometimes you
have seen frogs or some other amphibians
in the grass as they pick them up and
the elephants are very very smart
animals they will know it's hard to
shake the grass sometimes now if you pan
to the left of the bed those three on
our left you gotta see what I'm talking
about
now all those three this that one on the
right okay the big one against showing
us this back turn around this way so if
you look carefully her trunk doesn't
seem complete and it could be anything
it's very difficult to know an old
imagine the vet doctors will have an
idea of what should have happened but my
theories I just guessed
it could be anything then girl do baby
Ellie's enjoy the rain I would do read
say they do not they're too small where
it rains and I think the skins are quite
delicate and what should happen is
they'll always go underneath their
mothers and that way they're sheltered
from the rain so if the rain gets bigger
and scammy in different directions
elephants have been known either to read
the signs of rain as they come and if it
will be bigger than what we can do to
shelter their babies they look for huge
trees or big thickets
well they can always go under like the
ticket was in front of us possibly they
might move to the sticker to make sure
they'll shutter the young ones from the
rain too much rain and if it's going to
be cold will not be very good for the
calves
it could easily give them something like
pneumonia and you can see this
particular one doesn't have any tax
which wouldn't indicate her age is
definitely less than two years
well scoots to have seen my face but I'm
sure you'll see a face with a big smile
always the mine a very beautiful
elephant baby a very very good afternoon
and welcome to the beginning of the show
I am Sydney for me cozy and I'm
travelling with Dave who is my camera
operator for your questions and commands
you can follow us on Twitter hashtag
safari live I've already established
exciting but it's very very far at the
moment I just want to quickly get there
now I can see a huge head of the
Buffaloes rushing towards the vo Telepan
so those buffers were looking very
thirsty
so they don't want to come to the
Gallagher pen at the moment I've just
gone past the Gallagher pen when I saw
them from a distance I thought they were
going to opt for the Galago pen instead
of the Via della pearl but they've just
decided to go towards the Via della pen
so the Sun is very hot at the moment I'm
sure those poses
so I am hoping to see they spotted cats
during this drive today so now let's go
to the luckiest Tristan who's got the
spotted cat we do indeed we managed to
catch up with Hassan Oh who's well I'm
doing what I would imagine most cats are
doing at this point in the day because
he is very very sleepy you can see his
belly is moving at a rate of knots not
only because he's full but also because
he's just trying to control his
temperature it's a very warm afternoon
and that's crazy to think that this
morning we were all wrapped up in
jackets and we're feeling a little
chilly in that it's as hot as it is now
so he's heavenly breathing at the moment
just trying to kind of keep that body
temperature as down as possible and he's
found himself a nice little spot that
begins to log and you can see he's got
his little foot rest there so he's
feeling very very very comfortable with
life at the moment isn't that nice
now his killer is up in a tree like I
was saying earlier
well it's quite far from where we
actually are at the moment why he's
lying in this particular spot I'm not
quite sure but his kill is kind of his a
little sort of dip where we are and it's
on the other side of where that is in a
sort of drainage line now if any of you
watching a few weeks ago when we had a
very cool elephant sighting in the
afternoon or the thing was one of our
Safari lives that we did on foot the way
the aimée's walked very very close
that's exactly where we are with husana
which is quite cool so it just in that
sort of drainage section and he's kind
of found a very nice create to put it in
it's going to be perfectly safe there
from all of these scavengers that hang
around except for maybe his dad his dad
is one that he's got to worry about but
interestingly enough this morning we
obviously were following tracks all
around the hyena den as we kind of
finished up here and handed over to to
Brent and Jamie who kindly came and sat
for a while
during the course of this morning just
to make sure that hassanein didn't
disappear they got a notification that
there was a male leopard that was
crossing from Triple Aim or on triple
him and pretty much where we had been
tracking that male lip it all day so we
were very close
I think he was still around all morning
while we were driving around now who it
is no one is sure because there was it
couldn't have been her camera at the end
of the day because he was actually all
the way on Sullivan at Sullivan should I
say which is very far to the west and so
whether it's ten Ghana's first Safari
into arethusa or maybe Amphicar Zi or
maybe potentially even you know one of
the others that hang around it's we
don't know but maybe that explains why
we didn't actually see it this morning
is because it was a little shy and
skittish I'm kind of just avoiding us as
we went along but he just goes to show
that there is a lipid walking around now
that lipid walked all the way from Zoe's
app for a teller access and on to
Aubrey's so quite something to think
that there is another lipid that's
moving around if it's not in Ghana
anyway we're gonna spend our afternoon
with our lazy boy and while we do that
they'll send you across to Sydney who's
got something that is not being very
lazy at all at the moment you can see
now the buffers they've just decided to
start running one of them gave an alum
call like and they all just decided to
run away I'm not too sure if they have
spotted something dangerous here in the
area I'm just waiting for all of them to
go past so that we can go behind them
following them to the waterhole we might
be lucky and see what they were
complaining about now I can see the last
two crossing now at the road I am going
to push further and see if we can get
very close some of them are still very
far I can see there but a lot of them
has crossed already so I think now we
have got an opportunity to pass and go
to their waterhole maybe it's lions or
maybe they saw something small such a
snake which frightened them and decided
to run because there are no sign of the
Predators here where I am so these
animals they are much more gifted they
can sniff from very far and they can
hear from far I am not too sure if they
hear the Lions or any other predator
so I can see some of them are still
running towards their waterhole but
there was a very loud alarm call given
they didn't just run away first one of
them gave a warning call which gave the
other ones signals in order to run away
so now let's go to James who go to some
very interesting things by the Chitra
dam at the moment what we have here at
Chitra DOM is a pied kingfisher it is
not fishing at the moment I think it's
probably investigating the nesting site
that it has used before in the bank over
here we can't see him there but the nest
that he had is just if you go over the
top of my right shoulder there's a hole
in the bank there and we've seen them
nesting in there you can see there is
quite a lot of done around there as well
guano that's not from the king fish as I
don't think I suspect but that is mostly
Egyptian ghouls and I wonder if there
isn't an Egyptian no you know what it is
quite possibly hardly dar
it must be a nest there somewhere I know
that there was a nest in one of these
trees are Hardy darnest before but all
those little chicks seem to die I'm
afraid anyway now we see if they try
again here a to them we do also have a
lot of hippopotami there the hippopotami
in the last bits of water I'll say this
down is getting pretty shallow I think
you'd be able to wade just about all the
way across lots of places where the
hippos can stand all of those
hippopotamus they are standing they are
not floating so it gives you an idea of
how shallow it is a long way to go
before this dam dries up but it does
accumulate the kind of loss of water
accumulates over the years so unless we
have a pretty wet year it won't recover
you know what I mean into the wet season
now there's something very odd going on
on the far bank there Craig all of those
blacksmith flap wings are over there
there are about 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 19 blacksmith
lapwings absolutely unbelievable now
they're not supposed to be like that
they're quite territorial birds and they
nest in pairs
and so I have absolutely no idea what
they're doing
yes they are having some sort of
convention Mary what sort of convention
it is I'm not really sure I'll try and
do a bit of research and do exactly what
kind of convention is going on here
while you go to a buffalo convention oh
dear what's going on there how very
interesting possibly a little scuffle
between a young bull and a cow
certainly in the air there is the smell
of hippopotamus dung which of course
must cover the floor of this waterhole
all righty let's now goes to all the
Buffalo having all the water so the
buffalos has just arrived now by the via
Telepan I can see a lot of them out
drinking at the moment some are still
waiting to have a chance some of them
are also right deep in the dam trying to
cool up their body temperature some of
them are also standing under the trees
it is quite very hot at the moment here
where I am some are just playing in
water here so if you can look at the
conditions of these buffaloes you can
see that the bush is very dry but not
yet showing any impact when it comes to
the nutritional status because these
buffaloes are still looking very good
there are any a very good condition
so they must be feeding on lot of dry
grass and drinking a lot of water
Rosalyn they keep a phallus you can
easily stop them
all you've got to do is to keep a
distance you know animals they don't
judge charge they first consider the
distance between you approaching and
where they are if you approach to a
distance of about hundred meters all
these animals are going to be
comfortable with your presence if you
trespass and that hundred meters let's
say and you go through about 80 meters
you will be getting very much close and
that animals going to take a decision it
means at 80 meters is a critical
condition where anything can happen
however when the buffer is charging you
have got to reverse and give them a
space but if you are on foot you must
have to stand still and if there is a
nice barrier you must have to consider a
barrier and if you are you are with the
team Scout who is there responsible of a
safety it will then give you directions
and deal with the situation it's one of
the very much dangerous animals when on
food
so I can see now that the oxpeckers has
also arrived some of them are now
jumping on top of these buffalos when
they got here they were not escorted by
the Ox fixes they have just arrived
while the Buffaloes are here already
I'm so very much impressed with the
condition health status of these
buffaloes you can see some of these
oxpeckers right there on the sides it
looks very very hot at the moment that
is very true normally by this time of
the day is when buffaloes are hiding in
the big dongers the very big open dry
riverbed is where they hide where is
nice and cool and also in thick bushes
so the numerical art for drinking
somewhere just before the sunset is too
early for them to show up these
activities may be the problem now is
that some of the dams are starting to
become very dry and they are travelling
long distances from one dam to the other
so this is what is called a breeding
head
it is consisted of the females males as
well as the little ones so the Buffaloes
do have two kind of structures sometimes
you will see only the male's they can
form a group of basilar head together
feeding together and still go back and
join the head and they don't mind even
walking just by themselves so now while
still waiting for any developments here
let's go to Tristan who is still by the
sleepycat Hosanna
indeed he is very very sleepy a moment
and like I said I don't think we're
gonna get too much from a young boy just
yet I think he's going to unfortunately
only have a bit of a nap for quite some
time like I said we're quite loving the
fact that he's got his foot up and he's
got two feets up on at the moment on
this fallen over stump and he looks very
comfortable doesn't he I'm sure he's
doing that because he can get a bit of a
breeze on his tummy that will just help
cool him down but this is the back paw
and the front paw both perfectly poised
on his log making him feel very
comfortable I would imagine just now at
one point yet that leg completely
stretched over that log come and the
tresses oh he kind of was flexing his
leg out and he looks very very very kind
of relaxed and as though he was
reclining at a swimming pool on the
Sunday afternoon I suppose if you're a
lipid it's about the right time of day
to be sleeping and taking it very easy
and in weather like this I'm not
surprised he's got a meal he's at a busy
morning and so it makes sense what he
wants to have a bit of a nap but I'm
very tough for him that he managed to
get his kill back if it was his and was
able to get food so niconico view of
what's the breeding rates of leopards
depends on the area that you're in
depends on how dense the population of
other predators there is what food
availability there is what all of those
kind of things will dictate the amount
of Cubs that they have but generally
you'll find in terms of a success rate
in
this particular area that we operate
you'll find that most of the time and
the Cubs will kind of be it's about a 1
in every sort of 9/10 that actually
makes it to a full grow and territorial
adult which is not very many at all and
obviously that number it could jumps up
and down depending on the seasons and
and and those kind of things but it can
go as many as three out of every ten but
generally it's one out of every ten cubs
actually makes it to adulthood and
becomes a territorial individual whether
it be a male or a female so you know
success rates are not very high and
that's because in this particular area
very high density of other predators so
a lion hyena high density of male
leopard which is probably the number one
cause well not probably it is the number
one cause of fatalities within leopard
cubs you've got snakes you've got those
kind of things that cause a lot of
issues and even birds of prey and so
that you find in this area Cubs are
quite tricky to raise to adulthood and
other parts where this probably lists of
those areas where there's no lions or no
hyenas then they'll have a much easier
time of it but generally in those places
their biggest problem then becomes loss
of habitat and and human interference
where their Cubs will then get killed so
you know just depends on on the area
convents in this particular section
between one and three Cubs out of every
ten generally survives and how often
they will breed intake is always
dictated by whether or not their Cubs
survive if they have Cubs that died
before you know they become independent
you'll find it will take the female
probably you know a month or two until
she's actually starting to mate again
and then it's a three month gestation
period before shielding give birth so
often when they lose a set of Cubs it's
normally about five six months until
they have their next set if they have
comes that go independent well often
they mating before that cup goes
independence and they the ones that are
actually forcing that cobot sometimes
even when they're already pregnant and
Tonya was a prime example of that
she had Cubs and then pushed them out as
they were kind of as he was getting a
little bit older and she was already
pregnant right so we're going to keep
sitting with him but while we do that
James and be relieved is got something
very interesting
who really astonishing exciting here
there's a side striped jackal there it
is in the shades not the best picture
resides to objectively I'll ever get but
it's it's made a friend a water buck
ball they seem to be entirely
comfortable in each other's company
of course the jackal poses no threat to
the enormous water bucket bull and the
water buck bull obviously feels no
threat from the jackal but why they
should have chosen to lie in such close
proximity I couldn't really tell you
other than to say they found some shade
had got too hot and they thought well
you know what it doesn't really matter
we don't mind each other necessarily so
well that's fine we'll just stay
together that is very funny
and that gorgeous now we don't often get
to sit with these jackals because mostly
they're running away from us they're
quite skittish and so to find one that
has been basically cooked by the Sun is
quite nice it doesn't want to move out
of its nice cool shady patch and so it's
going to put up with us for the next a
while
now Lindy say what a great ticket
absolutely is erotic the side striped
Kjetil now I suppose for those of you
don't know jackals jackals are much the
same ecologically as coyotes they live
singly and in pairs the side stripe
often singly the black-backed normally
in pairs and they are predominantly
scavengers although they catch a lot in
the way of rodents and they will
certainly eat things was widely varied
as lizards and carrion like I said birds
if they can catch them miss Ling's
especially and I think they'll probably
even take the odd scorpion and the side
stripe jackal is known for eating fruit
not exclusively but it does eat quite a
lot of fruit in comparison with the
black-backed ah now I believe you saw
jackal with Tristan this morning that's
very interesting thank you um car for
reminding me of that
was it a side stripe or a black-backed
jackal that you saw this morning with
Tristan does anyone remember a hon it
was a black pact which in theory should
be slightly rarer in this area now when
we came driving along here we saw the
water backbone we saw it with a little
one and we thought oh that's odd it's a
it's a water bug car flying with the
bull and then we stopped and realized
that no actually they're not related at
all we have the wolf like side strap
jackal and of course the big water buck
ball neither of whom seem like they want
to move an inch today I don't blame them
Sunday afternoon and the Sun be very
nice to have a little bit of a snooze
and that shade myself I feel
don't worry I'm not going to I shall
keep searching around the place well
Fiona yes and no I mean jackals and
foxes are related in so much as they
come from the same family so they all
come from the cainy day or the dog
family and so do coyotes so do wolves so
do African wild dogs but I don't know
how closely related they are so what I
shall do is open my book and I'll tell
you right so they all come from the
order Carnivora which is the taxon apple
the group up from the family and then
they all belong to the canid a family
but they don't all belong to the same
genus so the African wild dog belongs to
a different genus but the jackals side
striped black-backed Ethiopian wolf the
European wolf the gray the gray wolf all
belong to the genus canis and you'd
probably find that they could interbreed
for certainly they could hybridize but
when you get on to the foxes that we
have here the bat-eared Fox the Royal
Fox the fennec fox the Cape Fox and the
pale Fox and the rumple's Fox and the
red fox these are all African foxes they
belong all of them but for the bat-eared
Fox to the genus vulpes the ULP ES and I
suspect that the European versions
belong to the same genus and the
bat-eared Fox has its own genus
it's called Otis ion which is
interesting so they do not belong to the
same genus as most of the other dogs the
foxes the jackal is much more closely
related to a domestic dog probably even
an African wild dog and certainly a wolf
than it is to any of the foxes that we
have it's a rather long-winded but
relatively detailed explanation of their
realization
to the other canids he's got something
he's eating something he's got something
quite nice to eat there oh that looks
disgusting so yeah you can probably hear
the game drive radio going a night year
deeply irritating definitely got a nice
piece of meat
alrighty well we're going away from this
dog over to some cats the cats are not
close by
yeah well that must be a very big party
jackals Nala's and now guinea hands
that's huge we may be having what could
have been a big party here a few minutes
ago we got the sausage the trip ride and
you can see all those females there with
the Cubs with the young ones and they
were trying to bring down or they give a
shot to bring down a buffalo let's have
a quick look on this one as close as I
can go and if you look at her closely
you can see she's panting and on the
shoulder you can see some blood sports
you see that panting that actually shows
definitely she was in a big action a few
minutes ago and the blood on the
shoulder there the front side because
her and they're the members of this
pride of lions tried to bring down a
huge buffalo but what is interesting as
they're just about to choke or it Oh to
suffocate it and kill it the other
members of the buffalos they are the big
herd mobbed and ganged up together again
as to this sausages excuse me on my head
and you might be going to show you now
where those buffers are at the moment
you're going to see how big that hard
was and the one that was attacked and
survived is in that had a
you want me to move for sure but you
consider from them very good now it is
in this hard which I think most of them
are Bulls males that there's one in the
middle that have survived and you'll
have a story to tell because it's
shortly before he was suffocated to
death
all these others that you see here Kim
and rescued it and got it out of the
teeth or the mouth of the sausage attrib
tried I'll be going a little bit close
to them
I've got fast I'll show you the Lions
and then I'll be going close to these
harder buffalos to see if we can zero in
on the one attacked le Gow that's very
interesting or good question
the Cubs of the substrate are here and
what happens when the Lions illegal go
to hunt they're always stay back of
course very quick message is sent to the
Cubs by the mothers stay put stay still
don't move and then the mother moved but
after the aborted the hunt the Cubs have
rejoined the mothers let's have a look
at them see if now they could be playing
and telling the mothers well done you
did very well
you didn't make it but chances are on
the next hunt
you'll definitely bring a buffalo down
Oh another play now Elega if you look
carefully from a distance you can see
this two cubs they're being very playful
and the mother is keeping a very close
watch on them
remember your questions are always very
welcome any nice comments like from a
legal please send them using hashtag
Safari live on Twitter and for those who
have never joined us before this
particular pride of lions is called the
sausage tree pride
kalenna great comment I mean he's always
a question of a safety in numbers
and either way as much as lay on snow
that Buffalo's is good prayer for them
they also know the dangers we face we
have been having the migration for the
last couple of months we have been you
know thousands and hundreds of will be
surrounding this area and zebras all of
them have gone further down south to
Tanzania to Serengeti National Park and
this season all that we have is what we
call a green season in green seas means
the Lions have to look for bigger prey
to hunt buffaloes giraffes islands some
big big animals so they know you know
the risk they face in Culina you're
right it was very nice for the Buffaloes
to come back I just got there and missed
by a few minutes and just mobs and
rescued one of their own so what I want
to do is maybe go close to those
buffaloes and see if we can identify
that's one particular because I think he
is still bleeding to me and Archie if
you allow me we're gonna move on and see
how close you can get to those boys well
I'll get close there but from my
buffaloes in Amara triangle let's send
you to other buffaloes in Douma in
Kruger National Park
from the buffers in the Maasai Mara to
the Buffaloes here you can see our
buffaloes because of the temperature at
the moment they are very much relaxed
now at the waterhole a lot of them are
done drinking I can see now it's just
about every fun there by the assuming
pool now
niconico viewer both of them are very
dangerous hippo and buffaloes the hippos
can be very dangerous specifically if
they found you between them and the
waterhole that is when they can be
dangerous but the Buffaloes these ones
problem is when it's too hot
they've got to find a nice shade and if
you come they're not seeing them and if
they see you from a long distance we're
not aware that they are there is when
they're going to give it a problem so if
you can check the hippopotamus it's one
of the animals who attacked quite a lot
of people in the world so in terms of
the group of mammals hippopotamus is the
first group leading when it comes to the
killing of people around the world but
the biggest animal the animal was
killing the people the most is not the
hippopotamus no the Buffalo is the
mosquito mosquito also falls under the
kingdom Animalia in Sector is just a
class
Trish that is a lovely comment at least
these buffaloes had something to drink
considering the season at the moment and
they enough water availability buffaloes
are in a very good condition Toby the
buffaloes they are ruminants the
ruminants are those animals which is
good a four chambered stomach some other
people they call it a compound stomach
or a complex stomach they've got a room
and a room in they've got rumen omasum
abomasum and reticulum so a rumen is a
big portion whereby these animals are
eating and saving the food which is then
later on taken back to the mouth and be
eaten again which is a process called
rumination also is called to choose some
card
so unfortunately buffaloes they are part
of the RET of Jack Taylor editor dr. is
a group of animals who are forming part
of the roominess
James the little ones indeed they look
like American cars also the South
African cows the look similar like the
baby buffaloes so now when they've got
the buffer the little ones like this is
when they can be very dangerous if you
go towards them on food
so most of feeding is taking place at
night during the day is just there time
to relax soon as the Sun Goes Down is
when they concentrate a lot on feeding
so these animals they look very big but
they can go very very fast x0 the reason
why the Buffaloes are now standing in
the water is that they already done with
their drinking now is about cooling the
body temperature so if there were a lot
of mud here we are going to see quite a
lot of males as well doing the mud
wallowing in order to have the mud and
the cover their body to prevent the
sunburn
so now from the Buffaloes let's go to
Tristan Tristan is still with us Anna I
am indeed still with us on and you can
see very little as change we had
vehicles come and go and so our boy has
been sleeping as well this is Ivy's date
really I suppose it's a very tough time
to me I'm sure he's going to move
shortly the funny enough as usual see on
his Raj wears on his shoulder area the
Sun is hitting him properly now so it's
starting probably gonna get quite hot on
that shoulder area and on his head and
you'll find when that happens then often
they do move and you might just get up
and move a little bit closer to where we
are and there's a nice shady block
there's kind of between us and him and
he might just kind of go into there you
can see the nice shady section I wish
that we had a bit of shade ourselves
unfortunately our shade is also
disappearing very quickly we're starting
to also get into the Sun a little bit
which is not as pleasant as I would have
hoped for I was hoping the Sun was going
to just come down a little bit to the
left in which case we would have been
perfectly aligned for some shade but
alas no Sun has positioned himself
perfectly so that he can get the best
shape possible now there's not really
any other way to kind of view him from
the other side there's almost impossible
to get him lots of tongue boots he's on
the other side so we're just gonna have
to be patient and wait for him to move I
think you know it's already cooled down
quite a lot considering compared should
I say - to what we had a little bit
earlier so I'm pretty sure it will be a
case just now and see for him to wake up
and move around I'm hoping before the
end of Drive he decides to show his face
and maybe go and have a little feed on
his carcass and you'll take him a little
bit of a walk to get there but I would
imagine that he's only in a really feet
as the Sun Goes Down I don't think he's
really gonna go up before then I think
he's going to enjoy his nap and I can
say I was a busy busy morning for him we
know that last night he was had a fairly
busy night he got bored and played the
Terrapins and then from there he somehow
magically flew to Philemon stipple it's
quite funny this morning because we're
all looking for him around Gallagher pan
and avid sailor pan area that northern
side and don't know why for some reason
I thought I'll just come check down you
and up in case he somehow got this side
but and no one expected him to be you
know when I spoke to Herbie afterwards
he said he didn't see any tracks I
didn't see any tracks for him either and
how they managed to get this side I'm
pretty surprised anyway he did and we
got lucky with the vultures if it hadn't
been for the vultures and then hyena
walking past when it did I don't know if
we would have found him to be honest it
would have been a lot tricky and this
kill would have not have been easy to
find now where he's put it so we got
lucky and I suppose a bit of luck is
always good thing especially when it
comes to leopards and we've had a tough
kind of day yesterday and you know this
morning wasn't going very well at all
until we got lucky late in the morning
so all good for now and hopefully he's
going to keep this kill I'm hoping that
his dad somehow doesn't snuff it out and
find it good sushi well the reason why
cats like to be clean is because they
got OCD so they they like to make sure
that every little bit of dust is off
them in case the cameras come around and
make sure that they are looking good for
the paparazzi that arrive every day
twice a day it's part of the contract
that they signed when they join us is
that they have to basically groom their
coats every single day and make sure
that they clean and tidy
you know we've got we've got a few other
members of our staff that are the Ragged
kind of looking fellas and so we don't
need to worry too much about that we
need some clean well-groomed cats and so
part of the contracts is that they've
got a sign on the dotted line is to make
sure that they clean now for the reason
why they clean well from the pure point
of view that most of what they eat is
meat and that means that they get bits
of blood and and things on them which
metz their fur and that can cause
disease that can cause attract flies it
attracts parasites and so to keep
themselves clean means that they avoid
having an overdose of those particular
parasites and irritations in their life
so if they have blood all over them
they're going to just be bothered by
flies all day long whereas if they clean
their code meticulously and they make
sure that they're well groomed then
you're going to find that they are not
going to be bothered nearly as my
it also means that their first self
stays in a healthy condition if it's
covered in blood all the time it's going
to start to you two stick together and
it's really not going to be very
pleasant at all and they're gonna smell
very bad that's going to alert prey
animals to them so it's all about just
making sure that they're nice and clean
and well-groomed so that they don't get
any little parasites all over them what
have you seen this in just him then his
coat but you can see Hasan is in
beautiful condition very few ticks on
him more we can't see too many is one or
two little flies that are in his coat at
the moment which you would expect
they're landing all over us as well and
that's more because we sweating that
these flies are learning us we've got a
few stingless bees and a few biting
flies that are trying to get the salts
and the liquid or fast whereas with him
you know it's probably due to the fact
that there may be other few little bits
of meat on them but generally that's the
reason why is that they need to maintain
a very clean coat for one to stop like I
say parasites and two to be able to not
smell bad and still be able to hunt
fairly good now you would think that
he's having a fit the way that he's
breathing shame he's getting hot now
because his whole head is in the Sun
husana all you have to do is just move
one meter and you'll be absolutely fine
but alas he's not going to anyway we're
going to wait for him to move I'm pretty
sure he will and while we wait let's
send you across to James who's got two
of the biggest animals we get Archer yes
we've got an entire herd of elephants
over here now I went on a little
training drive this morning and we
noticed a couple of large completing
trees that had been pushed over now
while we've been sitting here this large
car in front of us has pushed over yet
another large can read some preachers
and push it all the way over but she's
pushed it over enough to expose the
roots and clearly there's not a lot of
greenery around just yet and so the
trees their roots bark and stems are
still taking a bit of a hammering she's
also very very heavily pregnant
hello my dear very nice to see you
I hope you're not insulted look at this
this is this is special watch this too
big I think she decided it was just a
little bit too large she gave it a bit
of a test the one in front of her not so
much
I'm just gonna keep my voice nice and
low because she's pretty close to us
investigating each branch of calm
Britain we go that's quite a difficult
one to get out the ground that's it
little done now I think if she could
she'd go for the route rather than just
that little bit at the end there that
used to be attached to the route I'm
just watching her belly as world see if
there's any sign of a kicking fetus she
breaks it on her tasks
well you see mgn this is possibly not a
serious comment you've made but maybe it
is they are a natural deforestation
project and without them this landscape
as I keep banging on about would look
completely and utterly different
they are ecosystem architects or
keystone species she's not showing any
sign of discomfort with us so I'm just
gonna sit here while she walks a little
bit closer and has a look she's smelling
Craig's haircut not haircut his shampoo
I think she likes it Craig winds Blanc
straight over the top of us onto this
beautiful beautiful elephant this is so
special she's only about three meters
from us nine feet or so showing any
signs of discomfort
look how prehensile the tip of her trunk
is as you can she was just trying to
pull a strand of bark off that branch
and can you imagine how difficult that
must be keeping a body the side fed in
conditions like this now she is
definitely pregnant and Kathy that
situation will remain as it is for about
22 months so they'll have a gestation
period of just under two years which is
a very long time to be pregnant I
imagined personally no matter how I try
we'll never be pregnant myself and so I
cannot comment on whether or not a
two-year gestation is a trial or not but
I imagine given what I've heard people
say about the nine months that we have
as human beings your probably is quite
trying
she's just letting out a bit of gas and
now we have her youngster the reason
you've got bits and pieces of car in the
ways that I don't want to move with them
so close they've been so trusting of us
that I don't want to make a nasty noise
and now she's moving the other side
our brilliant question from a Japanese
viewer watching on niconico yes the
answer is that they would eat a little
bit of tree if the grass was green look
there goes it there goes a big can
beaten problem big can beat him tree
right down isn't that amazing
that's just fantastic I'm sorry we're
not in a better position I can move now
and we just keep answering that question
so the grass will go green and they will
almost universally then yes select for
grass but they will still eat some
leaves and they'll certainly go for
fruit get into a position where we can
see which bit of it she's eating trees
coming up so I'm just gonna stop here
now you can imagine with the 15 thousand
elephants odd that there are in the
kruger national park all of them or all
of the adults pushing over trees like
this from time to time you can imagine
how they are modifying this ecosystem
now some people see that and they say oh
the elephants are destroying the trees
we can't have that
well the elephants are probably just
opening up habitat for other creatures
look at that big piece of route she's
chose there we go it's like a really
tasteless carrot she's now eating
frg elephants don't go long without
water in fact I think there's actually
some statistic on that which two days or
so before they start to really struggle
I seem to remember reading it if you
just give me a minute or two I'll see if
I can retrieve it unfortunately not from
my brain but from my very impressive
mammal application here we go let me
have a look description oh we know they
look like they're large and gray skull
no reproduction reproduction no and
google says four days without water
I wouldn't necessarily trust that this
app that I have has got some very
impressive research and ischemia give me
a minute and I'll just quickly quickly
have a look-see
lots of interesting information here
habits 200 I just remember reading a
sentence which very nicely described it
it might not be here we go
200 liters in drinking session every
third or fourth day they will drink in
really really dry conditions we just
have to say every three or four days it
probably could go slightly longer
without then maybe five days but they'll
try and drink every day if they can I
think it's unlikely that these elephants
are around here by accident I think the
fact that we're so close to chitra dam
probably means that they're going down
there on a regular basis
wonderful she's not opened up a whole
yeah sort of a resource of tasteless
carrots for her friends right it would
seem that the sausage tree prides
attempt at the Buffalo have not ended
yet they seem to be about to make
another approach well done James with a
lease and Ellie's happened to be my
favorite animals because elephants will
never bow you they'll always be doing
something now back to the sausage tree
pride here in the morrow Triangle Kenya
and that's from a distance you can see
twelve others Wharton lioness that's
walking slowly towards these hard of
buffaloes now the Buffalo was talking
about is in the midst of this group now
I've been looking closely at them and I
think this is a bachelor hada one made a
difference between females and males
welcomes the buffalos it is the size of
homes the males have much bulkier heavy
horns and we shall see if we look at
them carefully they got like a boss now
you see that one to a right look on the
nose very carefully it got a very bloody
nose left bottom left of your screen and
this is the bathroom that has a story to
tell and two of the lionesses out guests
or one of them was trying to suffocate
it and then maybe two or three were just
trying to hug it down from the back but
shortly before that happened the main
group came and rescued it well for me it
looked like good bleeding nose but I'm
imagining those are all the teeth marks
or how deep the teeth went in because
players know once they suffocate this
big animals that's always an easy way to
subdue them and bring them down to death
now what our guess would happen much
later on the other buffaloes might not
want
to stay very close with this particular
one let's see if she turns back look on
the back there and you can see the
hindquarters especially below the tail
it's all bloody and that is a typical
formula for lions to bring their prey
down bring it down from the back and
then try to suffocate it
and Elijah Lyons a brie fast cuts and
lions can comfortably do out of 40 50 60
miles an hour but the females that we
had here did not give a very good chase
I guess and what what could have happen
is there was no mayor to help them to
bring down the Buffalo buffalo is a big
animus and they're very strong and lions
know if they're not very careful the
buffalos can easily cut them with the
horns because the heart is a very solid
and I think the moment the lionesses
realized all these buffaloes are coming
the best bed for them and to place if
they had to let go and that's exactly
what happened will now move on slides
will be down until they can see the buck
or the hindquarters of this particular
buffer one more time before we go check
the Lions and find out if they won't
come close to this particular Buffalo he
is walking down and if you carefully
sorry em come again with that Christian
for a Russian II
Russian yes I mean that particular one
looks strange in every way you think of
if you look on the left side he got so
much mad with the bed grace and
Buffaloes Dolores mad wala to keep cool
and sometimes to suffocate any insect or
person that they could have on their
body but either way he doesn't seem to
be similar to the rest of the HUD as you
say he looks a bit strange I would agree
with you and that's the one closes to
screen and I'm sure yeah that's one on
to push it away or he's just trying to
look and smelling the bloody bottoms
draft gal Alou is a pleasure to hear
your name and you'd like to know if the
pride will give a shot to this
particular Buffalo again and I'll tell
you a big yes a big yes because the
moment it has been attacked like this it
has weakened and these other buffaloes
may not want to be with him and the
Lions know he is not the same Buffalo
and not as powerful and his muscles are
not as good maybe to fight back so I got
a feeling either later tonight or early
tomorrow morning
this Lions will slowly and quietly try
and give another shot to this particular
I would say poor Buffalo yes that's it's
very possible Hrothgar see the amount of
mud he got on the left side unlike all
the others not sure this particularly
getting sympathetic with him staying
very close near his hindquarters and
that's not a good sign
Christon how long they take to recover
if nothing happens if nothing happens
from now I'll give it about two weeks if
the bleeding will stop he'll be in very
good shape most of the animals here in
the wilderness tend to recover very
quickly and what we do as guides if it's
anything natural for example predators
coming for prayer
we rarely interfere this one have a very
eg ribs sometimes they'll have lots of
mites and parasites just trying to
scratch itself hopefully don't bring
that phone tree down and if you're going
to see an thorn tree you can see it has
been eating little bits my elephant so
that one is a very important tree to the
Elly's and of course like now it comes
in very handy for very itchy Buffalo
remember your questions are always
wonderful to get all comments using
hashtag Safari live on Twitter these
buffaloes are debating how that may be
get rid of the one that is bleeding
because what will happen it will make it
easy for the Lions to come back and that
is the guy that's the victim who have
survived and will have tales to tell
maybe a week or a month from today
see how bloody he is you might think
maybe he was giving buff but lioness is
baying on their own without a meal and I
think that's why they didn't make it
well done Buffalo and maybe Lions can
try again and the Lions here will keep
getting closer closer to this heart but
the Hosanna
the leopard must be up now
he is up and he's gotten up into the
tree so we thought that the Sun might
get him moving and get him out of where
it was and so he wondered orphan he's
now gotten into the tree with his kill
and you can see there's still a
substantial amount of food there for him
he's done actually very well to hoist
this it must have been quite an effort
for him to get it up into the tree
itself so he's done he's sterling
sterling if it there'll be obviously a
little few chunks that are missing out
of it from Ines but there's still a lot
of food there for young husana to have
any good feed today and it's a decent
sized meal you know if you look at it in
relation to how big he is he's going to
have a few days on here I doubt that
this will be finished even tomorrow at
this rate you know it's not like he's
empty bellied the only problem is is
that I'm pretty sure his dad will find
him at some point in fact a lot of time
I sorting on I think it was a loss of
Tigana was actually walking right here
so you know he's does spend time in this
area and so you'll find it Isana might
not be able to keep this one safe from
dad once again but he'll definitely have
a good opportunity tonight to have a
really good feed and what are the
chances that we find him once again you
know week later on food really is a
showstopper husana he knows the win it's
TV and he just kind of makes sure that
he's available and yesterday was just
his prep day was making sure that he was
in fine fettle for this afternoon and
now he's kind of going to town the
problem is is he started feeding a
little on the early side which means he
might start to actually kind of have a
bit of an appellate so which is not
ideal but we'll see let's see how it
goes
at the moment he's plucking this carcass
as best he can he's trying to get rid of
all that long fur and that these guys
have on them and trying to kind of get
all of that off so he doesn't actually
have to eat it because if he eats that
it's obviously not good for his
digestive system husana be very careful
because the branch he's got his bottom
foot on does not look like a very sturdy
one I need a asana you had it fine there
boy
no we're going to reposition it again
you can see how mangled that carcasses
by the hyenas you can see how it's been
stripped along a lot of the joints and
you can see there's these areas that are
completely mess
with meats and say they've gotten in
under the skin and they've kind of
pulled chunks off of it so there's not
as much as it first looks like but they
still enough like I say to keep him here
for a good couple of days is a really
good meal for us on and he's going to go
to town I think now it is really nice
and full and that way if Dad does come
and steal it well then he doesn't have
to worry too much it me still had a good
feed and I'm impressed that he got it
back from my in a single thing with that
this morning was that those hyenas were
just so full that they just really had
no idea what they wanted to do they kind
of had no space left and they tried
their best to just sort of keep us on at
bay but at the end of the day it got hot
new tummies were full and pretty sure
that they were uncomfortable and so they
decided rather to try and move it on and
try and go and find a bit a spot in
order to go and rest and that allowed a
perfect gap for Hassan to get in so
Rachel they're not cleaning the kill
before eating what they're doing is they
just plucking off the stuff that's
difficult to digest so things like fur
one is it takes a lot of space in a
tummy that provides very little
nutrients in fact it's the stomach's
really battled to digest fur and so they
try and pluck as much of that thick fur
as possible you can actually see where
he's been pulling off you see how the
skin is is being exposed so there's
little white patches or where husana has
taken big mouthfuls of fur or ffunny and
he's trying to get rid of that so that
it doesn't basically clog up his tummy
and make things a little uncomfortable
for him so they don't really clean it as
per se they just I suppose try and D
fluff it in order to be able to get to
the really good stuff and not waste too
much space inside also now what are you
doing way is that better are you feeling
more comfortable now he's quite well
which didn't they I mean it doesn't look
as though it's going to fall out at all
but he definitely kind of play around
with it as he normally does take a the
SL eat the skin
no once they've plucked that fur they do
eat skin you'll find that very little
actually goes to waste with lipids they
they eat most of what goes on in there's
a problem is they just doesn't have the
the jaw power to you to crunch spines
and pelvises and even probably the upper
part of these
eggs will be too big for him and you'll
drop those down and things like hyenas
will clean that up and take it away and
I'm surprised that now that he's up and
feeding and kind of plucking away that
we haven't seen and you know kind of
wander in from where they've been
sleeping but I'm sure they will later
this is undoubtedly going to happen you
know these hyenas that know that there
was a carcass yes so they'll come and
search and sniff about and then come and
lie and wait for the next few days in
the hope that butts fall down but he'll
definitely heat portions of that skin
will most of the majority of that skin
once it's been plucked a little bit he
seems to have got himself in a nice
comfy spot to eat now as well if you can
see on the sea way he's positioned his
bottom he's got a little risk for his
tail as well and we're in such a perfect
angle because very seldom when you watts
lipids in trees can you be at the same
level as them you know normally you kind
of have this upward angle on them but we
are exactly eye level you can see where
he is in relation to iron this is big
steep Bank and he's kind of on a tree
that's growing off the bank and so I'm
literally looking straight at us on uh
from where I am which is absolutely
wonderful so it's a very unique kind of
perspective to have of a cat in a tree
and delightful one if I'm honest it's
going to be very pretty and once that
Sun gets at a nice low angle it should
begin beautiful golden lights on him a
little bit later which will be quite
nice if he's still up in the tree of
course and you never know how long he's
going to take to be up there yes I
suppose they are you know maybe some of
the guides not so much it depends
everyone's obviously got their own
personal favourites and they they kind
of have you know a sense of difference
amongst us is what makes us human but I
don't think there's a presenter that
works yeah nor a guide that works yeah
and particularly within you know the
wild earth system or safari life system
that doesn't have a very very large soft
spot for young hosana he's provided us
with so much at the end of the day that
we can't really kind of I don't think
there's anyone that sees were sort of
frowns down upon him he's really has
given every single one of us and if
exciting at one point or another and so
you know brain she's probably the
hardest when it comes to favoriting
animals he
he has a huge hot spot hot spot for some
spot soft spot hot spot soft spot there
we go
for husana where and so there's
obviously Jamie given that she saw them
growing up and and James we know as well
so I think everybody Sydney he's also
you know Sydney assisting on as his
favorite but I know he likes spending
time with Hassan and you speak to David
who was out from the Mara for a period
of time he loves husana as well so I
don't really think there is anybody that
doesn't I mean the guides here in team
are probably used the same I mean they
really have provided everybody with so
much and you speak to a lot of the
guests that come here that have been a
few times and he's one of the firm
favorites that often gets looked for and
by I guess that all repeats that I've
seen him before they want to see him and
even people that haven't you know
Komachi and he's a pretty famous leopard
now in fact you know if you think about
how many times he's appeared on big
television shows it's probably more than
even his mother in many respects which
is saying something so he really has
become a very special kind of animal and
even though we know that he lives a
natural life and then obviously our kind
of feelings towards him or pretty
meaningless in the grand scheme of what
he has to enjoy every single day it's I
I don't know it's it's a nice thing to
know that he's become kind of one of
these sort of legendary cat so really at
his early age I mean there's not many
people that don't know about him that
have been what one in the sabi sands or
to that even have come across a safari
live at some point so he's a very very
special cat in many regards and I think
he's given not any old you his views but
many of the guides in the area seriously
spectacular and of view into and lipids
life so fortunate is what we are to have
had a cat like this it's funny enough
today I was actually sitting looking
through old photos for some random
reason I found a drive that I had and
that I was looking for and I came across
a whole bunch of photos of with him and
Tumblr and Tenggara on chat race trip in
their their carcass to you then as much
as I loved spending time with Hassan I
must be honest there was a part of me
that was very sad that we don't see
Tommy anymore he really was one of the
most stunning looking lipids and kind of
seeing the two of them together was
always such a treat
I used to love when we used to get the
two of them in one place because they
were very different looking but both of
them have their own unique kind of
beauty and Hasan is a little bit more
brownie and a little bit more kind of I
don't know he's got this sort of
teenager attitude where his tumblr has
always been a little bit more serious
and and buts very striking looking lipid
and you forget how striking they are
until you actually kind of go back and
look at some of the kind of pictures
that you've gotten of them over time and
so I really wish if there was one liquid
that could make an appearance once more
in this area I would really want it to
be him I don't have actually any updates
on him I know some of you have asked and
I haven't heard anything to be honest
but I really really wish he would make
his way back at some point because he
was seriously good-looking fella I would
be intrigued to have seen what would
have happened between him and husana
whether they had been much aggression or
if he would have been much like Hassan
has been in terms of seeking around
sundean and even ting gana although it
sandy was far more aggressive to tumblr
than she was even to hasana
in that period where she sort of fell
pregnant and had clamber which is quite
interesting but you know it would have
been so nice to have the two of them
around I hope I hope that wherever he is
that he makes one last return back here
for a few days that we can spend some
time with him and see him once more
before he distributes out again but the
good news is least with tumblr is that
he spent some time he still within the
sabi sands system and that means that we
do get I mean not frequent so I wouldn't
say it's every day but we do get fairly
frequent updates on him and his
whereabouts and what he's getting up to
so so far so it was so good for him as
well it's been quite nice to know that
the two young boys have so far really
kind of taken to sub-adult life and
going into adult life very very well so
let's see
hopefully you're making their appearance
like I said see he was a stunning
running cat and his eyes are quite
something I think about Hasan is ours is
that they are very kind of different
kind of color he's got a sort of orangey
eyes which is not that's usual in
liquids action you don't see many lipids
with this kind of eye color you know no
mullah had it before and there's been
one or two others but it's very very
very few most
lipids will have that kind of light
yellowish
much like his mom had and so aunt Andean
and even shadow as opposed to a degree
with this very few that gets very deep
orange like what he's got or any of
those that get really kind of blue-green
colors those are quite unusual
used to be a time on my Allah my Allah
where they used to see a few they had a
few lipids with different colored eyes
which was quite something there was I
remember seeing a photo of one with a
brown eye and an a green eye which was
quite interesting anyway when you're
going to sit with Hassan he's going to
devour his meal and so we're going to
enjoy his company while we do that
though we're going to send you back
across to David who well will probably
tell you about just how much she likes
her sana as well as revel in the fact
that he's got some of the cutest little
animals that you get in the form of the
lion cubs alrighty good son of the chief
of Jummah we got now the tree pride and
the two new additions in the pride here
but actually apart from this - there's
another pair of two younger ones so this
old ones here gets it about three months
old but it'll appear of two new Cubs and
most likely one of these is their mother
now the both looking at the direction of
the buffaloes that we swirl yeah that's
a big yawn Wow
are us going to Yoon are you going to
you in two times here alrighty
how contagious is that - very normal
folk art see one yearns for the other
one to yawn and what they're looking at
is the buffaloes that tries to chase
alia and they're not very successful
another yawn I hope your sister yawns -
but she's maybe debating how they lost
on that kill I would say it was so close
yet so far having brought it down I
think that was the most important task
or the job was almost done but to lose
it I only heard it down and that was a
bit sad what out says maybe they needed
a little extra masses of an
in this particular area we are in days
male that we call Kapoor Lee and it's
always a very big strong male and strong
just like ting gana I am here now with a
Duke of dumit in Ghana who is showing us
something unusual this afternoon he's
trying to stalk the very big giraffe
and I'm sure that is highly impossible
it's not going to win that better but it
seems like the giraffe is walking away
and Kangana is also now carrying on
moving much more towards that side I'm
just going to keep following him until
we have a better sighting because I can
see from where I am there's too much
bushes in between so we are very lucky
to come across my favorite cats the Duke
of jummah Tinga Anna I love this
beautiful cat
so before we lose him I'm just going to
carry on now pull forward and see if we
can improve this writing so let's see
giraffe garrotting Rana is looking for
some troubles giraffe girl
a giraffe can kick they they've got a
very dangerous heavy kick which can
break his jaw he must have to be very
careful
so I can see that is right deep in this
thick bushes so I'm gonna find a space
to go deep in here so that we can see
him nicely so I can see now he's
starting to open up at least I've got a
space here to go in so he is now moving
towards this direction so we're going to
meet him at any time so let's hope he's
not gonna go to where wasana
is and disturb his kill I can see now
there is he
they might find some shade and rest a
little bit because the Sun is still very
much hot so most of the time Tigana is
doing his working activities the patrol
activities late in the afternoon today I
think is very much early so most of the
activities the patterns of the cat such
as lepers they are much more after dark
so ting honest territory is quite very
large because he is in charge all the
way from Rio Telepan is Tinga no you
come buffer sport is ten Ghana you go to
buffers Wooky sting Ghana and he has
been introducing quite a lot of
different females that shows you he is
very much powerful and the females are
interested on his genes
so these females they don't just fall in
love with enemies first they check if
they are going to have at the very
strong little ones so it seems like ting
Ghana does not have a strong competitor
at the moment he is still very powerful
I saw that not long time ago in less
than two weeks he introduced quite a lot
of three weeks he introduced quite a lot
of different females
so you can see is now again starting to
move towards that side way I must have
to keep following again until we get
much closer we are going going to pull
forward and see if we can have a close
contact
so what I like about this kind of cats
is that when they are moving from this
area to the next if they see anything if
any prey present itself they are going
to take an advantage so it might get
very interesting as I'm following here
Tania husana is true is very much far at
the moment he is just by the film on
scat line I can say is approximately two
three kilometers away from here he might
end up there these cats can walk long
distances non-stop he is walking slowly
like that but in a very short space he
can cover a very long distance I'm just
going to keep following following until
I find until I see what his intentions
are
this afternoon maybe he has got very
interesting intentions for us he might
hunt I haven't seen him for a while so
we're just gonna pull forward again and
see if we can get closer
so it's quite very thick here and quite
a lot of dead trees and knocked down by
the big animal the elephants please be
careful of the branch there so we are
just passing in between the branches
here
and these stumped somewhere here in
front which is blocking my axis
or we have married we are married
so I can't see where is at the moment
but it's ER
he's working all day
is he still now getting very far now
let's go back to wasana who is having a
kill indeed but I was just saying to
sensor now that this is not good news
for husana that ting gana is around
because if Kangana is on sites and on
property
well his nose will find this somehow
some way ting gana is going to end up
being at this particular caucus by the
end of this evening I'm sure of it I
tomorrow morning if he doesn't arrive
tonight tomorrow morning we are going to
find him sitting here with her Sanne
I have this funny feeling that he's
going to sniff this out somehow and find
his way here anyway
no sauna in the meantime he's having a
good feed
he's crunched through the ribs he's
eaten a couple ribs and enjoyed those as
a little order and now he's starting to
get into the really good kind of meat
inside there there nice really soft good
kind of juicy thick pieces of meat and
so he seems to be a very happy lad right
now he's looking quite chuffed with life
and slowly but surely getting round and
round but look at the size of his paws
and his claws that are coming out there
it's always nice when you get a leopard
in a tree like this because often when
they hold the carcass they all flicks
their paws a little bit and they
actually the toes spread slightly and
gives you an idea of just how big their
paws can be I mean you work out the size
of kind of his head and even the size of
that niala
and you can realize very quickly how big
those pores are they are absolutely
massive in comparison to the size of his
body so I still got a bit of growing to
get into those pores and in his paws
themselves will probably grow a little
bit too just quite something no Hasani
it's fine where it was you were very
comfy and very happy don't move it
around too much I was worried when he
does these things because knowing him
he'll drop it and if he drops it and
it's going to be lots of effort to get
it back up again but there we go he
gotten sorted out
I'm just needed to get it so that he
could not have to stretch too far as he
is eating with hey can you hear him
eating
he's chewing the skin there
might be a bit tricky with the wind but
try and listen for it and when he starts
chewing the skin again I'll just kind of
keep quiet and maybe you'll be able to
hear the shearing of that meat as he
uses his connections as he tries to kind
of go through all of that he's gonna
meet NASA that will be quite quiet he's
not actually going through skin at the
moment Meg unfortunately it's a bit of a
complex for her son he doesn't like to
talk about it you know is seeking laser
treatment but you know unfortunately
sometimes when you come from certain
lineages you know Hague just grows all
over the place and you become very hairy
he's but he's a bits kind of sheepish
about it so you'll find that he tries to
kind of groom it and keep it short as
much as possible goes for a try maybe
now and then just so that his hair
doesn't get out of control because he
doesn't want to be a hairy Leopard at
the end of the day he wants to be easily
good as possible as a possum look as
good as possible and so you'll find that
he goes to the barber quite really be to
make sure he's not too hairy and also
sometimes he new tried he doubled in
waxing for a while but that didn't
really go very well he didn't enjoy the
wax and so now he rather he goes to the
premium barber and has his little kind
of special cut that he gets that's
called the Hasan especial and he goes
along and that's how he actually ends up
getting the sort of look that he's got
is his barber knows him well now and
makes sure that all is well and fine no
toupee would not suit him at all and he
once thought about going he told me once
that he was thinking about going for you
know a mohawk and then he decided it
didn't quite suit his eyes because he
wanted a green mohawk he didn't want a
you know a normal colored spotty one and
then he realized I was in summer because
he wanted to blend in with the grass so
he thought if he had a gray a green
mohawk that he would look rather chic
and rather cool and he had blend in
better but we managed to convince him
not to go for the green mohawk instead
he keeps it nice and short sees he's but
back in Army Cadets in that he he likes
it in a kind of decent way now to be for
real and not joke around as much as we
are know his hair is not really much
longer than most other
means about the same really maybe I
don't know I haven't looked that closely
at others in comparison to him but his
fur looks pretty much the same as most
leopards I've seen it doesn't look to be
too much thicker longer than what I've
seen on others that's for sure
he's definitely at least a normal sized
tongue which is always quite nice
because you know we know how come when
his tongue is a little bit large anyway
well or sonna that face battles to try
and eat whatever he's trying to eat with
a face that doesn't look like he's
really enjoying what he's actually
trying to eat
oh boy what are you doing well he does
that then looks a bit dopey doing it it
sends you all the way back to the Masai
Mara and to David with the Cubs and it's
time to exercise build in the muscles
and you can see these two youngsters
here jumping up and down running chasing
each other in the grass there they go
running after each other and ideally
this is what will happen for them maybe
another two years three years from now
or they'll need to go run and hunt for
themselves and the mother is just
watching them and you know wishing them
luck in life keep playing keep building
your muscles it's drizzling a bit here
but the far how it's designed on these
cuts it helps to write always always you
know the rain just falls on the skin it
just slides down minimal at any age from
four months four months of five let's
say they will always be allowed to join
in the hunt it's not easy because for
example few minutes earlier Oh like half
an hour 45 minutes ago
I'm not sure mean a move you had me oh
you are watching I was talking about
this particular pride went trying to
hunt a buffalo buffalo is a very
dangerous animals because when they turn
back oh when the tables turn back and
hunters you know the hunters become
hunters it becomes very tricky
for the lions and they do not want to
take any chances and the Cubs will
remain in a particular place and they're
toward or given instruction of the
message where their mothers
stay still so six months they can be
allowed to watch and see what the
mothers can do the temperatures have
really cooled that Otis that's a very
good jump and she just landed on the
back of the mother very playful cabbies
here they enjoying the rain as much as I
am NOT but likely I am into the car and
part of my converse are rolled down for
those for joining us now this is the
Associated tree pride of lions and this
is one of the females of Cubs who about
three months old always five in total
when you have the whole pride together
the other four are not very far from
here and they're trying to bring down a
buffalo that's one of the other one
Kathy I agree with you and the mum knows
she got a lot of work to do to keep pace
with him because they are younger
definitely than the mom they are full of
energy so for her to keep up with them
she'll have a lot of work to do if you
consume the screen drops coming down and
that's the rain that's building up now I
think they have gone behind that salmon
mound and they could be playing hide and
seek and that's maybe one of the
auntie's just watching and lions are
very social cards if the mother of these
Cubs would miss to watch over them
definitely one of the sisters will keep
watching where are the Cubs now we're
going to wait cause it's getting a
little bit duck and we want to follow or
go a little bit closer to them but let's
the meantime go back to Sydney and find
out how ting Ghana is doing
at in Ghana is now walking in between
the dry trees and dry leaves no rain
here at all la cámara is having some
rain at the moment which is what we are
praying for here in South Africa
at the moment they can see that in Ghana
has got a mission is going to somewhere
so I'm going to just keep following this
hope is not going to wear asana is
because mostly can pick up the scent
from a long distance about these kills
so I'm just going to drive again further
until we get him again
so I am just keep following Kangana who
is now heading towards the eastern side
of the game reserve so let's hope is
gonna get to a very nice shade and relax
was maybe an art [ __ ] so these
artifacts can dig big holes here and
some of them is difficult to see you
just feel away neonate so I can see that
now in Ghana is marking his territory
look at that
so his every time using the urine
scratching and marking from the back
legs so it's just going now around the
termite mound I want to see where he's
about to go
he's not coming out so let me rather
drive and see if he is not relaxed
against the termite mound a for this
time and what is very huge maybe he is
enjoying the shade of the termite mound
I can't see him so it means he is yes
day is he against the termite mound he
is looking at something here now he's
very much relaxed so at least he's going
to use this termite mound for now so I'm
gonna have to pull back and find a very
nice spot by the other side I am NOT
alone at the moment by this sighting
they are some of the vehicles here I'm
just going to try and have a space where
we can see this thing are much better
so now we can go to Tristan with Hassan
indeed we are with the Sun and we are
thankfully not getting the runaround
like for Sydney is at the moment Sydney
is getting taken through horrible place
I know exactly is and it's not pleasant
at all now here comes lioness it wasn't
going to be long until they arrived
don't worry husana you safely tucked in
the tree and so these guys are not going
to worry you that's all there they come
I knew it wouldn't be long until they
got you it had to be you know one of
them that would arrive is that in female
that's darling it looks like a that's
arriving now but and I represent sure
through all those branches is it might
be you can see she's just below us at
the moment so we kind of parked in a
very precarious spot in many respects
I'm hoping that diners do come in and
keep Cesana
up in the tree because I know how he can
be he will eat now and then he'll go and
find a spot just to go and sleep but if
lots of hyenas arrive that'll keep him
up then hopefully you'll find a nice
little branch to have a good nap buttons
you can see look at how he's breathing
he's jammed so much food inside there
and you don't think he's got much space
left in fact his tummy is getting wider
than his shoulders at this stage which
is a bit of a worry he is in full
sausage regalia right now he's already
in his Halloween costume he's going to
go as a sausage as a little frankfurter
this year that's what he's decided
KitKat's wolf because most the blood was
kind of leaked out of this carcass this
morning so when Lions were feeding and
when we left this morning we went passed
away it was actually killed and you
could sense the hyenas first stylist and
it's just this big puddle of blood there
so all of most of it would have drained
out already and that's why we're not
seeing it too much and you can see
there's huge chunks missing at this
stage and so most of that would have
disappeared during the course of that
kind of feeding process and so a lot of
the blood is already gone so remember
that that carcass has been dangling up
there the whole day and so you know it's
much like um I suppose anything if you
make a huge hole in it's a new dangle
it's somewhere
for 12 hours he's going to be a blood
that's going to drop out and you can
actually see the damage to that think
the Pony Olives hoof even has been
half-eaten so his aim isn't really cause
a lot of damage all over the place
Masana are you watching the onion is
carefully walking away so hyenas come to
join us up on top here and is milling
about behind us at the moment
shucks ah mmm never eaten y'all a meat
like this and I'm not sure whether or
not it would be considered tough to a
leopard but I mean I have eaten an yalla
before but never one that's been kind of
in the bush that's all farmed niala
service was it slightly different look
at that doesn't he look happy with
himself he's kind of hugging his carcass
as if to say yes you may have gotten one
over me this morning but it is mine
and when that farm niala I suppose and
maybe if it's killed in the right way
it's not tough at all it's actually a
very nice meat to have hasana you've got
butts sticking out of your teeth this
you see these got any piece of and there
we go that's good well done boy I can't
have things hanging out of your mouth
you've got to look good you saw TV
appearance tonight doesn't look like
he's two the two brothers and so yeah
and Jana is actually pretty good tasting
stuff it's not the best but it is okay
mrs. Ellen he is Fat Boy slim at the
moment look at the size of that tummy
Oh sauna you're going to roll out of
that tree he almost looks like that
cartoon you know the one where they
inflated and that's when he kind of
looks like at the moment so now we're
going to fall asleep on our caucus
enough feeding has all been too much for
one afternoon I was going to kind of
just relax watch the sunset while he
sits and eats or sleeps on top of his
hello boy isn't that beautiful
see a little bit of sunlight just
catching his eyes as well which is quite
nice he is really going into a
magnificent leopard isn't he he's also
full filling out by the day
I'm not surprised because his bindi is
never empty just he was kind of plowing
food in there and so it's not surprising
that he's getting bulkier and bulky as
the day goes on his head is definitely
really got developed a lot since this
time last year you know this time last
year so I had a kind of young male cub
kind of appearance where he's starting
to sort of seem or seemingly starting to
look a little bit more serious and a
little bit more kind of bulky and that
typical kind of male leopard to look
about them where they get these massive
kind of heads and shoulder areas and you
can see little Jew life has started as
well so he is getting to that kind of
male leopard phase where and they are
quite intimidating when they kind of
reach that and they look at you and
they're but these kind of like I say big
shoulders and big neck area always
wonderful to see but that is one happy
cat I would say at this stage of life
come a long way hasn't he is quite nice
when you think about his kind of story
and what's taken place in his lifetime
it's not been an easy life that's for
sure and the odds of him surviving as a
male in a pretty lipid-rich
area like this probably was not very
good given he was only a year old but he
took to it very well I mean he was
within the first sort of three four
weeks of Karuna disappearing he was
already starting to kind of kill in
parlors and end their likes and so you
know he really has done very very well
all things considered and he's done one
little jaunt through the central part of
the sabi sands and decided nap he
prefers it up here and has come back and
is just taking it easy on this side of
the world that's whereas he had a lot of
competition down there you know Anderson
and Flat Rock are not two leopards you
really want to mess with too much both
are quite big boys and suppose it makes
much more sense to come here and just
deal with dad for a while and every now
and then pay him tax in the form of food
and then carry on
you most definitely even he I mean if
you know hyenas make a lot of noise and
then whooping and cackle and there's
lots of kind of fighting amongst them
that can definitely attract ting ganas
attention he can hear it from quiet away
away and then maybe move into this area
so I wouldn't be surprised if that's the
case if we could attract attention of
many others you know where Hosanna is at
the moment there's kind of a fringe area
this could be a place where we could get
should duly arriving we could get Tandy
here we could get ting Ghana we could
get hooker Marie we could get that
unknown male you know even in four cars
he wasn't that far away from here when
he had his kill started in the first
time we kind of saw him with Hasan Anton
garner so you know it's it's not always
the best spot for him at this stage I
mean he's gone he will have some
competition here and any noise that
hyenas make will attract the attention
of their of those cats as well as maybe
even something like lions the in koomer
pride when we followed them yesterday
walked right past here you'll see on the
right of this tree there's a tall tree
over there and the increment prior to
this walk just behind that tree in that
direction so you know he's not kind of
off the beaten track if you want to call
it that so he will have to keep a bit of
an eye out now what are you seen husana
he's kind of looking off in that
direction at the moment now he's decided
whatever it was is okay maybe some
hyenas or messing around that's where
the carcass came from so I wouldn't be
surprised if there's maybe a hyena
that's just chomping down on a few
little bits that are that side right
well we'll search and wait we'll see
what comes of his attention and and
while we do that did send you back
across Tooting ghana who's also looking
around much like his son so you can see
that in ghana is now heading towards the
Juma area not too sure where exactly is
going because he's just changing
directions all the time now he was
facing much more towards the touchwood
side now he's looking at Juma sight so
which I'm gonna have to turn now so that
we can see him clearly as he is
disappearing towards the dry dry
riverbed and here is very much think it
might be very difficult for us to see
him nicely we are going to wait and wait
I can see where he's going
might be difficult for
so maybe his plans are for going to a
sauna and see if one has got something
there and still the food as usual
they're lepers they they catch quite a
lot of different animals I haven't seen
them catching a fish but I saw them
going after a crocodile and I have seen
them going after the insects and also
the reptiles
so crocodiles anyway apart of the
reptiles I can see him right here now he
is going much more towards the thick
bushes look at that so here I am going
to work very hard in order to find him
clearly so I must have to go to the
other side and see if it's gonna come
out now
so I don't want to lose him I'm just
going to keep following otherwise we're
going to lose him here because the bush
is very much big so let me make sure
that I'm very close to him as it's
moving
so now let's go to James for some
updates absolutely hopeless I've been
today driving around like a lost well
wind in a gale force wind if you like
we've searched Torchwood we've searched
Chitra there's nothing on the radio
that's come through and well at least we
have gorgeous picture of the Setting Sun
we're now heading back towards Chitra
and lady Starfire rs ABC show starts in
precisely 40 minutes in fact from now
and so we're heading back to Chitra
where we are guaranteed at least to have
some hippopotami I was hoping to bump
into quarantine the male leopard or
something like that here on Torchwood
but alas and alack that seems not to be
possible anyway it's a glorious
afternoon so I'm not going to worry too
much about that isn't that pretty
you can see the Drakensberg mountains
there in the background stretching some
1000 kilometers down the escarpment of
South Africa and soon it will sink over
there the nocturnal creatures will
hopefully come up and for our TV show
and yes likewise I'm all hope also
hoping for a last-minute leopard as many
of you are hoping for one for me that
will become the first minute David of
the TV show it has continued
seemed to be the only one who can't find
anything here
Tristan this morning managed to find
what he has this evening
well I wouldn't say everything I feel
like Sydney's racked up a few more
animals and I have this afternoon I've
just been sitting with one animal really
and thoroughly enjoyed my afternoon with
the little chief he's been his normal
self really slipped for a while and then
he was is posed ever so wonderfully for
us in the tree isn't that just a
beautiful view of him I know obviously
it's not so nice to see the NYADA kind
of dead underneath him and the sort of
internal cavity there and I'm sure a lot
of you probably are a little squeamish
on that but the rest of it is pretty
spectacular like I say to be where we
are with him in the same kind of eye
level is not every day and so he's
chosen a spot in this rather tricky tree
that's a lot of said used to have a
really decent view of him which has been
quite nice so I've thoroughly enjoyed my
afternoon if I'm honest it's been very
very nice and any afternoon Sunday
afternoon spent with the leopard is a
very good Sunday certainly beats the
Sunday afternoons I used to spend back
when I was at school and I had to drader
the thought of having to do homework on
a Sunday because I'd lifted all weekend
and and then had to kind of panic
stations try and finish everything up
before bed on the Sunday night so
definitely a much better way to spend a
Sunday night Sunday afternoon is to be
with the leopard rather than thinking
about homework that I hadn't done it's
definitely not the Sunday blues did you
also get that MOS sensor you as well on
a Sunday we used to panic about the
schoolwork that you hadn't done yes I
think we've all been through that
exactly especially the older you got the
later you left it an intervention you
would end up like a missus at two
o'clock in the morning trying to finish
things up or you used to think about
some sort of excuse that you could tell
the teacher as to why you were incapable
of doing your homework over a 48-hour
period of no school so you know you'd
think of things to do I never really
used to actually think of too much and
get away with it to be honest I never
was good at making excuses I used to
just get in trouble raining more than
anything else I was better when I went
to high school in primary school I was a
disaster you know it's not very good at
doing schoolwork and those kind of
things I'd prefer rather if Ben
playing sport then doing any homework of
any sort whatsoever schoolwork it when I
was in primary school seemed like a
complete waste of time to me it was just
time that I had to spend inside rather
than being outside playing cricket or
rugby or soccer or something like that
and so I did not I did not agree with
learning years exactly counting an
alphabet we're not high up on my list of
priorities of things to be done in a day
but anyway he supposed survived as well
time ago tie school did a little bit
better
did you leave your exercise book at home
every day Senza yes since I said he used
to use the excuse that he left it at
home or he couldn't find it or I think
we all use that one at some points one
point or another funny enough there was
a we had one guy at school that's he did
his homework the one day he was a
diligent kid I mean he used to get his
stuff done and he did his homework and
one of my friends who was particularly
naughty and decided that he hadn't done
his homework and he was going to be in a
lot of trouble and so he asked if he
could copy this guy's homework and being
you know a nice guy thought you know
what not really into it but okay he'll
allow some copying to take place but
this poor guy did his whole exercise in
pencil and so what the guy did is copied
it and then erased the other guy's
homework and didn't tell him I mean I
know it's not funny and we shouldn't be
laughing but then when this poor guy
went to show the teacher he thought well
I've got done all my homework is going
to be no problems here and I need to
open his book and see that there was
nothing that was on the page whatsoever
and he got into the world of trouble for
lying about the fact that he had done
his homework but obviously eventually
kind of the teacher look closely and
could see that it had been erased but it
was very funny at first although it's
you know that poor guy I felt sorry for
him in many respects I mean exactly it
does feel like something husana might do
if he had homework he would probably be
naughty like that and decide that he
would rather you know somebody else do
his homework he'll leave tumblr to do
his homework while he kind of goes off
and goofs around right now while hasana
carries on feasting with much glee let's
send you back across
Sydney who's got a rather calm Tinka on
her by the sounds of things so you can
see now that Ching Ghana has got a nice
place to rest his right on top of the
hill looking at the bottom now you can
see he is the king in this place because
he's watching his territory from the top
at the moment so he has been walking for
long distance from the buffers who came
to here but now I can see that he is not
thinking about anything he's just relax
but he's still listening to what is
happening in the area he always
surprises me when saying he's relaxed he
always proved me wrong that he's not
relaxed every time he works up the head
and starts to look for some day
so unfortunately I couldn't manage to
see if the stomach is full because when
I got here when I got him he was
drinking already so I couldn't manage to
see him before drinking if there is
something in the bellies or not but
something in the bellies when it comes
to this kind of animals it does not
guarantee that this animals not gonna
hunt if any opportunity arises
clifford leopards are very awesome
indeed by looking at this cat you can
see is so very beautiful with quite a
lot of rosy spots and then you can see
also here where the necklace is is
different from asana
and fortune ghana as well looks
completely different so each one of them
has got its own spot pattern
so now let's go back to asana and see
how wasana is going to close the show
well he's going to be feeding his
sausage tummy is what he's going to do
to finish up the show this evening he is
going to try and scoff down as much food
as he can as quick as he can I wouldn't
be surprised that he eats himself silly
like this and then he's going to come
down the tree and either flop down or he
might take us on a bit of a walk to go
and get water unfortunately it's very
far away
oh hello boy he looked so good at the
moment isn't that cool
yes it's tough to eat so much isn't it
he's just watching where we are that's
very very cool now like I said I mean
the waters not closer he's gonna have to
take us a little bit of a walk if he
does want water but at the moment he's
just kind of staring off into the
distance to kind of pose as well as he
can for all of you to get your last
screen shots for the evening so he's
really kind of giving us the best sort
of afternoon the tree could have asked
for he's chosen a nice little spot in
the tree and we have been thoroughly
spoiled by being able to sit here and
watch all of that unfold which has been
very very good
now of course obviously it hasn't just
been me that's been kind of spoilt it
sounds like Sydney's had a wonderful
afternoon David in Mara sounds like it's
been epic up that side of the world as
well and then obviously James with his
Ellie's sounded very very cool too so
we've been spoiled all round I think all
presenters can be thoroughly happy with
their afternoons work now remember we
are not done for the evening you can all
participate in our s ABC TV special and
we will be going live again in about
half an hour time so we look forward to
seeing you all there but from all of us
it's been an absolute pleasure we'll see
you a little bit later otherwise we'll
see you tomorrow morning on the Sunrise
Safari